(audience clapping and cheering)
- All right, y'all, it's the holidays,
and we've picked out something
perfect for the season.
Trending on social media,
this is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering and clapping)
- You all know I'm a sucker
for a well-decorated Christmas tree,
really any Christmas tree.
I love Christmas.
But getting the lights
and ornaments just right
can take some serious work,
especially if you're not
smart and buy pre-lit.
Whatever.
That's why I love this hack
an Alabama man came up with
after and while enjoying a little wine.
(upbeat jazz music)
(audience cheering and clapping)
- That's a resourceful
man, I'm just saying.
We have this master inventor
on the line right now
watching on WVTM 13 in Birmingham.
What's up, Mike?
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Hello, Kelly. (laughing)
- [Kelly] All right.
So, Mike, you gotta set
up this scene for us.
So you didn't have a ladder.
That was a very clever thing you did.
- No, actually, the way
it started out was...
Of course, it's a wonderful time,
to have Christmas and put the tree up.
But this time the wife
bought a different tree
and she brought in two boxes
and I thought, "What the hell?"
You know, "This is a
construction site now.
It's not just taking it out of the box
and setting it on the coffee table
and putting a bulb on it."
So, yeah, I got the stepladder
and I got ready to put the lights on it,
turned around, she's walking
away with the stepladder,
said I had way too much wine already.
So I had to think fast and
that's where the broom came in.
- It was so clever.
And you are so welcome on
this show, anytime, man.
Your accent is... I'm loving it.
(audience cheering and clapping)
And you are so funny.
So this kind of... this blew up.
This made you famous in town, right?
- [Mike] Oh yeah, yeah.
Of course, I live in a little town.
I shared it with the
people at work, my friends,
the people I hang out with,
and, well, within no time
they're spreading that
(beep) around everywhere.
So that's (voice drowned out)
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- I would love to hang out with you.
(Kelly, audience and Mike laughing)
You are a bit like a member of my family.
It is insane how we are similar.
Thank you so much, Mike, for
the innovative, creative idea.
That was a very smart thing
to do with that broom.
Because it's the perfect
bristles, you know, to go through.
That was very smart.
- Oh yeah.
- Thank you for sharing.
(Kelly laughing)
- I'm liking your post right now, Mike.
(audience clapping and cheering)
And I'm loving you.
That's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of Precise,
the go-to pen of The Kelly Clarkson Show
want to honor truly,
truly incredible people,
just like you.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Oh, that's great. Thank you.
- [Kelly] Thanks Mike.
Thank you to all our guests this hour,
Cher, Laila Lockhart
Kraner, Big Time Rush,
(voice drowned out).
And on the Day of the Elf,
you all have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change it.